so first of all do you have your
acceptance speech ready for the enjoys
work I don't but I mean a surf board
would be nice that joint hanging on your
wall would you use it it's very
practical gift I've never been surfing
so maybe I'll be maybe I'll try another
superpower I'm really afraid of sharks
so but not see otters apparently no you
saw the figure it's the most adorable
thing tell me that this the otter is
going to be in the new season
I like really campaigning for it his
name is Harvey he can be a villain is he
his super powers massive hugs and he
really his limbs really well he just
constantly distracted Supergirl so she
can never go save anybody so it is such
a Supergirl animal no wrath like she's
so she just loves cuddly things so was
it like having another superhero alum
Erica Durance joining you for the new
season I'm very excited about it
obviously everyone was very saddened to
hear that Laura Benanti couldn't come
back but completely understandable why
and Erica is the perfect person to take
on this role as car's mom and just being
a part of the mythology and Smallville
for so long is so great I've met her
once and she's lovely and you know she's
been Coover right so she knows everyone
there everyone loves her she's just a
good energy because she always just like
recommending restaurants feel I can't
when they just look like you know I got
a better place to go she hasn't yet but
I'm sure we'll have that conversation
yes now it looks like you guys are just
having a blast
I like seeing you here together at
comic-con you look like you really enjoy
some company it is a bank oh yeah we
kind of like each other yeah we're lucky
we have a really great group we all
genuinely like each other and love
hanging with such long hours on sevens
we love hanging out with each other
everyone everyone has each other's backs
and we care about each other and that's
all you capsule
now you must get this a lot with you you
know you're cutting an icon now
especially for young girls and young
women that like like superheroes up or
love the idea of a strong hero how does
that impress upon you well I don't
really consider myself the only one
doing it on our show I think we have a
lot of strong women on our show and the
network I mean the CW that's what's so
wonderful about it is we've got Jane the
virgin and crazy girlfriend and Katy
laughs on legends of tomorrow there's so
many strong females representing females
from every walk every walk of life and
and different types of strengths and
showing how just the complexities of
being a woman I'm proud to be a part of
it and the way that I can do it wearing
masks from the Cape is a dream